Ebas meteoric rise to dominate
the personal transport
market has made it one of
the most successful and the
most hated companies in history,
along with his controversial CEO,
Travis Kalanick.
It has developed a reputation
as being iron fisted,
cruel and relentless in
its pursuit of power,
inspiring an equal measure
of admiration and loading.
Uber has turned the traditional
taxi industry on its head
and provided customers
with a more user friendly way of
getting from point a to point b.
okay.
In the mid 19 nineties with the
worldwide web still in its infancy,
the undergraduate computer
science association,
or you see a Ucla University in Sunny
California was a breeding ground for
future millionaires.
The association was more
of a clubhouse sweat.
Likeminded students could relax after
class while they played games and talked
computers,
though not a founding member rate,
young San Fernando Valley residents by
the name of Travis Kalanick soon became a
central figure of the group.
Colonic was pursuing a double major in
computers and business just like the baby
of Internet companies up
north in Silicon Valley.
The USCPA was mostly fun and games.
However,
soon it's members stumbled
upon an opportunity because
there were no firewalls
back then.
It was possible to search for files on
all connect to computers and then index
the results.
The group decided to replicate the
time honored practice of college.
Kids lending out their record albums,
but they were able to extend the
lending for Tennessee to anybody who was
connected to the Internet.
The idea was molded into a
startup which they named scour.
It was a tool that would scrub it,
networks files,
looking for mp3s.
Travis Kalanick was not involved in the
founding of scour because he was doing
an internship within cell,
but as scour became established
and grew in popularity,
he'd jumped on board.
He was in charge of
marketing and fundraising.
It was in this role.
There's colonic developed the on the job
training that would serve him in later
years living at his parent's house.
He would spend up to eight
hours a day on the phone,
wheeling and dealing in
order to attract investors.
In 1999,
his efforts paid off when Hollywood power
player Michael Ovitz port $4,000,000
into scour in return for a 51 percent
share in the company within a year.
However,
the writing was on the wall for scour
it's success had attracted to competitor
who would do things better.
This competitor was napster.
Scour is fundamental.
Problem was that it
didn't scale these sites.
Words often crashed through over use
and scour was running out of fresh
concepts.
Meanwhile,
napster was paying close
attention to scour problems.
They introduced a tweak I listening
to a song would automatically make it
available to others.
As a result,
napster quickly became a viral sensation.
Scour tried to gain grounds by
moving into sharing movie files,
but ultimately they were deemed the
company went into bankruptcy in two
thousands.
By the end of that,
with scour gone.
Twenty four year olds,
Travis Kalanick had no
college degree and no job.
He needed a new plan
and they needed it fast.
Within weeks of the folding of scour,
calumnick was onto his next project.
He teams up with former scour partner
Michael Todd to form red swoosh,
which was essentially scour
recreated for business customers.
This new startup would allow companies
to use the Internet to share similarly
large files with their customers.
Enabling large file movements
was already big business,
but red swoosh is competitive.
Advantage was that it capitalized on the
asset light strategy to keep its costs
below that of competitors.
Redswoosh pushed and pulled files from
personal computers owned by others,
foreshadowing what uber would later do
in connecting writers with drivers who's
caused represented massive
unused capital on city streets.
As the CEO of red squares.
Colonics job was to pitch the
potential clients as he had done it,
scour who sat a forensic
work based proving to be the
quintessential workaholic,
just what it is,
gone Ganju and efforts.
However,
redswoosh became a victim of
the peaking of the Internet.
Bubble investments dried up and
tensions rose calumnick blamed for
mismanagement,
sins wrangled for him to be
kicked out of the company,
colonic capital willing,
and it looked as if he had found
a savior on September the 11th,
2001.
He was scheduled to meet with a potential
partner investor named Danny Lewin.
Lewin,
however,
was on board American Airlines
flight 11 from Boston to Los Angeles,
which crashed into the
north tower of the world.
Trade Center is the one that he was
the first day after confronting the
hijackers by the end of 2001
red swoosh was out of money.
Reprieve came in the form of a father and
son team who had made a fortune from a
semiconductor business,
James and Jerry Chow.
They agreed to pour $300,000 into the
business in return for a 30 percent stake
over the next few years.
Red swoosh,
stumbled along,
propped up by further investments,
and then in April of
2007 major competitor,
Akamai purchased the company hiring the
handful of employees of the company,
including Collar Kalanick was now 31
years old for his share in the sale of red
swoosh.
He had pocketed around $3,000,000.
Yes,
he was now tied to a large
corporation as an employee,
something he had never experienced before.
Over the next year,
he works to continue building
the red switch brands.
At the same time,
the restyled himself as an angel
investor for young entrepreneurs.
He bought an old house in the Castro
and Old San Francisco neighborhood and
named it the jam pat that's became a
meeting place for fresh tech based ideas
with no money.
Calumnick reveled in the role of is the
oldest age who had been there and done
that.
His blog,
which was called swishing,
became essential reading in it.
He described his home,
the jam pad as a place where entrepreneurs
regularly come to hang out to rap on
ideas,
to jam with other entrepreneurs,
to play tennis and gears of war,
and to have a fantastic healthy meals
made by the jam pads in house chef colonic
quits,
red swoosh in late 2008.
He spent the next couple of years biding
his time as he examined new business
ventures.
He also threw himself
into leisure activities.
He became a part of a group called
the random traveler society.
They would randomly spin a globe to you,
decide where in the
world they would travel.
In 2010 colonic got heavily involved with
the q and a website called formspring.
He invested in the company
that was soon running the show.
At the same time,
he was still looking
for other opportunities.
He was introduced to a smartphone APP by
the idea of an old friend named Garrett
camp.
The APP was called Uber Cab and it's
allowed the user to make a quick contact
with the limousine in
the San Francisco area.
Galenic began sharing his time between
formspring spring and Uber Cab.
Within a few months it became obvious
that he had to choose between them.
The people that form spring were
pushing him to become their CEO,
but in late September,
2010,
he walked into a board
meeting and declared,
I'm going to be Uber.
In the summer of 2008 Garrett camp,
a miles managed Canadian software
designer was waiting for a cab in San
Francisco Bay area.
He'd been waiting nearly 30 minutes for
a cab that had promised to be there in
just 15 when he saw an empty cab
from a competitor company come by.
He hailed it and got in.
A few minutes later,
he got a call from the original
taxi company asking where he was.
He replied that they relate,
so he had gotten in another taxi.
This became a regular occurrence for camp.
Eventually both taxi
companies that he dealt with,
luck,
soar and yellow blacklisted him.
This annoying the young Canadians who
just so happened to have $75,000,000 in
his bank account after selling his first
startup stumble upon hailing a cab was
now more difficult for camp.
The taxi switchboard companies who had
cut him off as soon as they saw his
number one evening while standing on
a street corner and running late for a
date.
He had the proverbial light bulb moments.
He had his brand new
apple iphone in his hands.
That phone was gps enabled.
Why couldn't he requests a cab directly
from his phone simply by pushing a
button that says,
pick me up this way.
You cut out the dispatcher,
entirely gamble,
so knew that the iphone included
a thing called an accelerometer.
This allowed for the tracking
of not just where a car was,
but also how fast it was moving with this
technology map could be generated that
showed the beginning and end of the
trip along with its duration and price.
It would also have lengthy rider with
the driver cutting out the middleman and
August the eighth,
2008 campaign.
Thirty $5 to reserve the website.
Uber.
The cab dot Khan,
he then began to elicit feedback
about his idea from his circle of
entrepreneurial friends.
He also interviewed a taxi driver who
complained about the hours that they were
sitting idly waiting for a fat.
Slowly other people
began jumping on board.
One of them was Travis
Kalanick in early 2009.
Travis contributed in an idea that
became pivotal to the future of the Uber
Model.
Rather than buying a fleet of vehicles,
which camp was envisioning clinic told
him that he didn't need to buy cars,
just give the APP to drivers
and let them be free agents.
They would work when they wanted to work.
The focus for both men was on limousine
rides rather than normal taxi cab rides
clinic signed on as an advisor that
you go with a 10 percent stake in the
company.
It took over a year to develop the APP
by January 2010 campaign candidate again
testing the service.
They also began making plans to
launch operations in San Francisco.
Colonic had a 27 year olds,
General Electric Middle
Management employee named
Ryan Graves to oversee these
San Francisco launch.
Graves began visiting marriages.
Do you sign up?
Limo drivers.
The service launched in late May of
2010 with just a handful of drivers and
customers.
The original customer base
came from twitter followers
who had been keeping tabs
on what the entrepreneurs were obsolete
colonic and graves who had been made CEO
again,
working together to find investors
after receiving a lot of knock backs.
The C funding rounds raised one point two,
$5,000,000.
It was at this point the clinic
decided to go full time with Uber Cab,
but he wasn't content to play second
fiddle to a guy that he had hired.
He orchestrated a demotion for graves
and claims the title of CEO for himself.
He also demanded that his shareholding
rise from 10 percent to 23 percent.
On the very day that kind nick became CEO.
The company received a cease and desist
from the San Francisco Metro Transit
Authority and California
Public Utilities Commission.
It stated that the name Uber Cab meant
that they were a taxi cab company and
under the authorities direction colonic
solve this problem in five seconds,
he simply changed the name of the company
from Uber Cab to simply uber at the
time of his taking over the operation.
It was tiny and it made
plenty of mistakes.
On Halloween of 2010,
they offered a discount to writers.
This created such a huge demands
on their already busiest day yet,
but it left a lot of people unable to get
a right despite this growth was steady
throughout 2010.
Then over the 2011 new year period,
it absolutely blew up.
Word of mouth was responsible for the
exponential growth in Uber's customer
base,
but finding limo drivers,
well that was a different story.
They didn't have the same social media
habits as the young about towners in need
of a limo,
right?
Only licensed drivers were
eligible to drive for Uber.
They all had customers if their own
and none of them were prepared to go
exclusive with uber
either began giving away.
Iphone is preloaded with
the Uber App to drivers.
This enabled them to
increase their driver supply,
to keep up with the ever
growing demand in San Francisco.
Having proven the model in San Francisco,
colonic started to replicated in other
cities under the guidance of the head of
operations,
Ryan Graves,
they turned their attention to Seattle,
Chicago,
Boston,
and Washington DC.
In each city.
Graves made connections in the tech world.
First.
This created buzz and
attracted cutting edge Jesus.
Once the word was being generated,
they began looking for drivers and
working through government regulations.
As they moved from city to city,
the Uber team began
refining their playbook,
refining the system,
and making us more efficient.
This process became one established
buzz in the tech community to assess
regulations.
Three,
recruiting drivers for developed pricing.
Five,
we local media and six capitalized
with social media buzz.
In the early days,
calumnick was a master at
local public relations.
Promotion would start with a blog post
in which you would relate how much he
loved the city,
where they were moving in suit.
He would highlight it's key attributes
and then he would talk about how much
greater the city would be.
When Uber had introduced
their service by 2011,
the job of securing investment,
it was much easier in February,
benchmark capital pour $10,000,000
into the company at this point.
If it was valued at $60,000,000,
the company had 9,000 customers and one
point $8 million dollars in net revenue.
It was estimated that
it would get to $100,
million dollars.
Gross revenue within a year had
achieved that goal in six months.
As we burst sprang up in more
and more cities across America,
it began to receive pushback.
The sixth city that it went
into was Washington DC.
Before they could get it off the ground,
whoever the city's taxi commissioner
announced that it was operating an illegal
taxi operation on Martin Luther King.
Day Two Thousand and 11,
the commissioner ordered an uber which
took him to a press conference at the
mayflower hotel.
He then proceeded to impounds the
driver's car and issued a $20,000 tickets,
but either they didn't back down.
They assured all drivers that they would
pay all of their fines and took the
moral high grounds in public asserting
that they would not a taxi company and
therefore not subject to
regulatory provisions in one city.
After another taxi companies,
the taxi commission and local and state
agencies came into uber to shut it down.
Under the guidance of consultants,
Bradley Tusk,
Iba fought back.
They ran social media
campaigns to stop the opposers,
often meeting them in court.
The public were overwhelmingly
on the side of the company,
but there was one thing that Uber's
customers were not happy about during busy
periods such as rush hour
into bar closing times.
It would apply surge pricing with the
rates going up during these peak demand
times.
Surge pricing had the effect
of encouraging more drivers
to work and encouraging
some customers to find
the cheapest service.
Both of these results is
the demand on the service,
but it also infuriated the customer base.
Many of them blamed the unfairness of
surge pricing at the foot of CEO Kalanick,
who quickly became known as a cutthroat
business man who refused to listen to
consumer sentiments.
By the end of 2012,
Uber was operating in 27
locations in that year.
They also introduced uber x
providing rides and hybrid cars,
but it was also the year that Uber faced.
It's first serious competition.
It's getting from a young San
Francisco company called Lyft.
Lyft was a ride sharing business whereby
a person would slap a launch pink
mustache on the grill of their car and
then pick up those you're in need of a
ride for the shared cost of gas
and a little extra donation.
Usually this would work out to be less
than the cab fare for the same distance
to use a smartphone app that
was modeled off the Uber App.
Lyft was a hit with young people
who preferred it's friendlier,
more laid back.
Image riding in a limo was
starting to look elitist.
As a result,
uber sat about
restructuring its game plan.
It would rebrand itself with a focus
on getting a from point a to point B as
quickly and inexpensively as possible.
Uberx,
which had started out as an ECO
friendly alternative to a limo,
became the means of being
traditional taxi services.
In early 2014 colonic hard
former Amazon executive,
Jeff Holden as product development
manager holding identified two things he
found lacking in the uber system,
the ability of the writer to communicate
beforehand where he wanted to go,
and the driver's ability to navigate that.
He oversaw two new features
to fix this destination,
input by the writer and turn by
turn navigation on the driver app,
both features where it hits,
and by the end of 2004,
Eva was operating in
262 markets worldwide.
Uber was now a genuine phenomenon,
but it was a phenomenon that
had attracted a lot of enemies.
Now,
a lot's of that animosity was thanks
to the brash nature of the CEO,
Travis Kalanick,
his outspokenness and inability to
hold his tongue made him the offender.
In chief clinic was the poster
boy for political incorrectness,
one stating that he could land women
as quickly as a person could summon an
uber.
Colonics.
Dificid personality only underscored
hoover's growing reputation as a bully in
the marketplace.
Reports were publicized if some
underhanded tactics used to undermine
competitor.
Lyft publications began labeling Uber as
an evil company and describing a ceo as
an an rand's loving libertarian nutjob.
In some cities,
it became politically correct
to avoid either altogether.
It was in a strange position worldwide.
It's business was growing
from strength to strength.
At the same time,
however,
it's reputation was tanking.
Things went from bad to abysmal.
When an uber driver in Delhi was
convicted of raping a passenger,
something had to be done.
I didn't have to be done quick.
In 2015,
Uber brought on a new executive to
oversee digital and physical safety.
Joe Sullivan,
he had a long to do list including a
stricter management of driver activity.
Things were tightened up to the extent
that Iba management can tell if a driver
is holding his phone while driving or
braking too hard or going too fast.
During that year,
another new executive,
Sally K said about us taking
and overcoming a slew of
local regulators who were
intent on stopping uber in its tracks.
By the beginning of 2016,
Uber was on a more even keel rather
than lurching from crisis to another.
In an attempt to change its image,
the company teamed up with mothers
against drunk driving to encourage young
people to take an uber
rather than drink and drive.
It also partnered with hospitals to
make it cheaper for cancer patients to
return home from treatments.
Travis Kalanick has been working on
introducing driverless cars to the Uber
makes since 2013.
He loved the idea that it would no
longer rely on the most uncontrollable of
business variables,
people,
autonomous vehicles would be far safer
as robots are not subject to drowsiness
or distraction.
Further robots would
be cheaper than people,
but in 2013,
the technology,
it wasn't ready yet.
By February of 2014,
Uber was canvassing the world looking
for top robotics talents or purchase a
pittsburgh company
called Carnegie robotics,
making it the kernel of
it's self driving car team.
Then in December of 2014,
hired 60 researchers from the
national robotics engineering center.
After two years of development,
Uber announced in August
2016 that it's caused.
We're ready for unlimited showing.
The call has worked,
but they still require a human engineer
behind the steering wheel just in case
something went wrong.
Uber are today still working
on their driverless car.
In that quest,
they are in a race with
the likes of Google,
apple,
and Tesla,
the latter of which is rumored to be
considering its own ride sharing business.
All of this competition will
ultimately result in a better,
cheaper service for those of us who are
wanting to get from point a to point b
as effectively and cost
efficiently as possible.
So I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put our brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a
notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time.
Every Monday and Thursday.
Won't put out a new video also,
if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive over
there on the right and as always,
thank you for watching.